muito bom dia a todos
é eu sou o benja satula e foi falado
sobre o crime a ação social e atitude 22
anos da minha vida passei nos escuteiros
e contínuo e durante estes 22 anos
bastante gente trabalhou para minha
formação do meu caráter
tornei-me advogado e tem estado a
trabalhar essencialmente no crime e o
cumprir o culpa no crime e não não irei
dar aquele som sofrimento
o que me preocupa é a atitude da
sociedade angolana e guiar do crime e
que tem estado a assistir e duas de
curso surgiu na comunicação social nas
redes sociais notícias de um crime a
sociedade mobiliza numa e noutra
barricada a sociedade mobiliza essencial
nem contra ou a favor
acolhendo diretamente a versão com a
comunicação social passou
acreditem que no crime há bastante cheia
há jeito da parta do lesado e gente da
parte do suspeito e que o bloco quer
outro sofre bastante com a notícia ea
nossa atitude deve ser uma atitude
estruturada e não uma atitude
desnecessária por coco aparelho que
surge normalmente são opiniões não
fundadas opiniões fundadas em nenhum
facto e quando as opiniões fundadas em
nenhum facto tem maior levasse que as
opiniões dos factos propriamente dito o
que acontece que uma família quer outra
sofrem bastante e é facto isto que eu
gostava que nós enquanto sociedade
tivéssemos uma especialização
especializar significa deixar
se a lista deixar com as pessoas que
trata os assuntos a resolver isto até
que de fato possamos ter uma ideia
fundamental daquilo que aconteceu e o
fundamental é a opinião que veiculamos
poder traduzir efetivamente nosso
caráter
porque se permitirmos uma opinião
infundada uma opinião inconsistente e
uma opinião sem fatos concretos podemos
rapidamente emitir uma opinião bem
analisada e podemos efetivamente
banalizar o nosso próprio caráter na sua
própria personalidade pública
o facto estamos a emitir opiniões tanto
emitir opiniões sem que exista factos
concretos sobre aquela o acontecimento
o que nos deixa preocupado
o que nos deve preocupar efetivamente o
problema da administração da justiça
porque cada um de nós rapidamente
podemos ser vítimas ou podemos passar
suspeitos e então se a administração da
justiça não escrever corretamente
funcional podemos rapidamente
transformados também em vítimas vítimas
não do crime vítimas não do da injustiça
e da impunidade mas fundamentalmente
vítima de uma máquina da acção da
justiça que não funciona
ora e o que não preocupa e qual é a
minha mensagem principal aqui é ao lado
do primo um posicionamento completamente
oposto em relação a uma ação social
qual é a nossa atitude em relação à ação
social como é que nós nos portamos
versão ele porque é um país real a um
país real
há jovens crianças e 12 uvas em luanda
no lucapa no loco se no lubango no
larica à espera uma ação concreta da
nossa parte
espero que nós possamos fazer alguma
coisa em prol delas sem que cruzamos os
braços à espera de uma ação eu venha do
estrangeiro mas cada um de nós poder uma
ação por atestar realidade concreta
o facto as pessoas precisam
na nossa opinião do nosso esforço da
nossa entrega da nossa dedicação e nós
esta geração as gerações passadas às
gerações vindouras terão alguma coisa
terão alguma atitude diante desses
factos diante da miséria alheia diante
do sofrimento diante da falta de acesso
à informação
diante da falta de acesso aos meios de
comunicação as novas tecnologias de
informação esta geração a geração
passada jackson embora tenha alguma
atitude
aqui em legalização social
o fundador dos escuteiros tem uma frase
com os escuteiros usam eternamente que é
a melhor forma de cerdas felizes é
contribuir para a felicidade dos outros
ou seja ao lado de um sucesso legítimo
do sucesso profissional cada um de nós
tem ao lado de uma realização plena da
nossa vida aquilo que eu chamo um
egoísmo legítimo do tornar um grande
profissional do ter condições adequadas
a minha vida eo meu estilo de vida
ficamos por aí eu conseguimos fazer uma
transcendência conseguimos passar para
lá daquilo que é necessário porque
acredito que nós temos duas categorias
cidadãos nacionais ou estrangeiros duas
categorias de cidadãos uma são aqueles
que tendo adquirido um sucesso
acomodam-se por cima do sucesso e vive
com toda a legitimidade
o estilo de vida que escolherem para
cima outras sal que tendo atingido esse
sucesso tendo atingido um patamar
entendem que é preciso fazer mais e o
mas é pouco as suas capacidades humanas
as suas capacidades intelectuais o seu
esforço ao serviço dos outros e quando
colocamos nosso esforço ao serviço dos
outros
começa o facto aquilo que o fundador dos
escuteiros diz a melhor forma de ser
feliz é contribuir para a felicidade dos
outros porque se nós não contribuirmos
para felicidade dos outros rapidamente o
que a acontecer é que estamos a fechar
como diz nesse grupo
o egito mas isso não é o que mais
importa o fato que importa é que
possamos servir os outros e tivo então
diz nesse tema
mas o dezembro passado deu nos uma
experiência diferente
vivemos numa plataforma que chamamos
natal rua e no natal de rua o que
aconteceu foi uma coisa espetacular
porque temos consciência que bastante
gente e gente boa
há de faltar a ação ou a falta de tempo
e mobilizamos a sociedade para
participarem de alguma forma em luanda e
em toda a extensão do território
nacional
grupos locais mobilizaram-se para isto e
nós tivemos nos arredores de luanda
encontramos pessoas aqui nos arredores
de luanda no dia 24 de dezembro não
tinham se que um litro d'água não tenham
se que com um quilo de arroz e com os
kits que fomos fazendo doados consiga
não jannone mos conseguimos em prestar
estas pessoas não um bolo rei e não um
capaz de natal mas conseguimos que as
pessoas tivessem uma refeição condigna
no dia família no dia 25
e de facto de entre várias pessoas com
quem tivemos contato há um senhor nos
arredores de luanda a brincar nos
podemos nós podemos tomar a refeição
consigo ele disse
os senhores não são dignos de comer
aquilo que eu como de fato quando
entramos para a casa do senhor
percebemos porque é que ele não estava
naquela notícia e sentimos que aquela
ação era a ação esperada aquelas
alteração desejada porque o fato temos
de ajudar e podemos ajudar não temos de
esperar por ninguém
cada 19 pode fazer isto cada um nos pode
transformar o mundo e dizia mahatma
gandhi
a arte da vida consiste em fazer da vida
uma obra terra e de fato fazer da vida
uma obra da arte e viver com arte e
viver com arte não é decerto do meu
ponto de vista com bastante respeito a
opinião alheia não é ficarmos acomodados
na nossa própria o nosso próprio sucesso
no nosso próprio profissionalismo e sim
doarmos aos outros e se nos doarmos aos
outros em qualquer dimensão com qualquer
missão com qualquer profundidade em
qualquer segmento social estaremos
efetivamente a viver com a mãe o que nós
precisamos hoje em angola e não anda no
capa numérica no bairro na china no
bloco se londuimbali longonjo é pessoas
que vivam com arte e viver com arte
de fato vivemos com arte podemos
perceber olhemos para os modelos cada um
nós tem seus próprios modelos mas eu
escolhi estes mahatma gandhi com o
advogado é um advogado de sucesso
poderia ter escolhido ficar em londres
não ficou voltou à ilha poderia ter
continuar a usar fatos gravatas das
máscaras que existe não usou e promoveu
uma campanha de independência com
não-violência liberdade sem violência
luther king uma de 13 de calcutá nelson
mandela poderia ter feito coisas parecem
áfrica poderia ter feito coisas
diferentes com o poder que tinha não fez
viver com arte e este meu apelo é que
cada um de nós
hoje possa efetivamente pensar possa
fazer uma introspecção e pensar será que
eu vivo com arte
será que utilizo o meu sucesso
profissional para colocar ao serviço
daqueles que precisa o centro no
conforto do meu salário da minha maneira
saiu das minhas condições e e olho
apenas e enxergou aquilo que está no
quilômetro quadrado da minha própria
família e não olho para os outros
se cada um não chegar a uma conclusão é
depois dessa resposta obviamente
estaremos a ter uma resposta positiva ou
negativa sobre o estilo de vida que
escolhemos para nós próprios
ainda vamos a tempo ainda vamos a tempo
e vamos a tempo de fazer uma coisa
melhor
é uma coisa que não caracteriza a áfrica
sempre que estiver no centro de um
projeto sempre que tivermos a viver com
arte é fundamental
começamos a preparar o sucessor porque
nós temos bastante líder
temos bastantes líderes mas dos grandes
problemas penso eu em fair mão tudo isto
é primeiro não prepararmos sucessores
segundo não nos preparamos para a sessão
eu conheço meus senhores e minhas
senhoras é que cada um de nós faça da
sua vida uma obra dá muito obrigado